knowledge is indeed power but the path  from knowledge to power is not immediate  there are stages one needs to follow and  they could be summarized in the  following sequence knowledge awareness  control Power knowledge breeds awareness  that is the consumption of knowledge  leads to a collection of wisdom nuggets  that when properly construed can raise  awareness awareness is the ability of  the individual to make sense of oneself  and consequently of the world around  them once this process manifests itself  one is able to transition from a state  of cluelessness and incompetence to a  state of control and power when I say  power I don't mean power over others but  power over the things you can control  and you can control only what you  understand what you are aware of